[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
let's uh let's go
i'm ready
okay mr vladigama
and we go with e4 p45
we have decided as
and we haven't faced e45 that many times
but if you guys remember
we made the decision to play the four
night scotch
which
i advocate as a really good opening for
beginners and intermediate players
because it enables you to bring all of
your pieces out and it really enforces
uh the ability to play with with all of
your pieces it's not a gimmicky opening
it's it's an opening based on very sound
principles you open the center and you
develop quickly and the four night
scotch is the move d4 in this position
and it's also a pretty dangerous opening
if black is not accurate he takes d4 a
lot of people okay so bishop c5
okay bishop c5
uh is
one of the multiple possibilities in the
four night scotch
now white's got a couple of moves here a
couple of possible moves one of them is
to drop the knight back to b3 but the
most principled move
is to defend this knight with bishop e3
this also poses an immediate threat
we threaten to capture the knight on c6
and win the bishop on c5 because the
queen is going to be hanging okay and
this is already an inaccuracy black is
just conceding
the tension in the center
giving us the two bishops
and uh giving us you know a bigger share
of the center castles
now how should we proceed in this
position
what's our priority
well
first of all it's quite clear that we
need to complete our development we need
to do so pretty fast but the thing is i
want to also preserve our two bishops
right so we want to complete our
development but an even bigger priority
right now
is to keep the two bishop advantage it's
an open board we want the two bishops
right
now bishop c5 might come to mind but
that just walks into d6 that that helps
black
so we retreat bishop b3
i'm anticipating rookie 8 and after
rookie 8 we'll need to find a way to
okay not ricky at h6 that kind of lets
us off the hook
now this is a good
situation to practice deciding where to
castle
it's important to have that intuition so
for example i look at this position and
within a couple seconds i have a very
good sense of where i want to castle i
want to castle queenside because the
moment h6 is played that's already a
hook
in my mind i'm seeing
the potential of going g4 g5
and exploiting the hook we also have the
two bishops we have a bigger share of
the center all of those things is going
to make a situation with opposite side
castling a lot more fun for us
than for our opponent because we just
have better attacking and defensive
capabilities
so we can start with queen d2 or we can
start with f3 but definitely queen d2
is i think the most flexible way to
begin king h7
and we can't play f3 we're not worried
about knight g4
because of the simple bishop f4 and then
we chase the knight away from g4 so we
can castle
but the move f3 isn't only played to
stop knight g4 it's also played in order
to reinforce the e4 pawn
and to prepare g4
a lot of you might might wonder what the
difference is between h3 and f3
and that's exactly the difference h3
doesn't support the e4 pawn
uh so f3 is kind of automatic you know
in in the sicilian this is called the
english attack setup where you go f3 g4
and potentially h4
now we can also consider if we if we're
putting on our russian school of chess
hats
what move could we consider throwing in
just as a
an improving move that you often see in
these positions we're not going to do it
right now because it's unnecessary yeah
so king b1 is a good idea
in in many of these positions and
there's nothing wrong with it inherently
it's just that black has so little going
for him on the queen side
that i i feel more inclined to just
start the attack let's go g4
95 that's a good move
that's a that's a very very good move
now this is where we have to be a little
bit creative when you're attacking you
have to think outside the box rather
than just making
straightforward moves
you know that
uh that often lead to squandering the
attack so here's how i'm thinking about
this well we want to defend the panel we
don't want to give up f3 if we give up
f3 our entire pawn structure collapses
on the king side
okay so
we can defend f3 in several different
ways but we want to find a way to defend
that pawn
while also contributing
to the attack in some way
and if i phrase it that way then you
might come up with the move queen g2
that's an excellent move i think because
once we play g5 notice how the queen is
going to be nicely positioned on the g
file where it can
partner up with the rook and exert
tremendous pressure on g7 does that make
sense
so here we violate the rule which says
you should do stuff with the least value
piece
because we want the queen here anyway
and and now
g5 is going to come with tremendous
effect he can take on f3 that's possible
knight f3 queen f3 bishop g4 is possible
but in the ensuing position we're going
to have two pieces for a rook and as
i'll explain after the game the two
pieces prevail in this case
all right
knight g8 very passive
so we can play g5 as planned
but after g5 he might meet that with h5
so here i think it's it's worthwhile to
be very patient
and to complete our development with
bishop e2
now what move does bishop b2 also
prepare
what are we preparing with the move
bishop b2
and i'm going to play the move in the
interest of time
we're preparing f4 absolutely
notice that i'm not just
you know closing my eyes and playing g5
when we first can because he's played
this so passively we can afford all of
the niceties of the position we can
improve our position to the maximum
before really stepping on the gas pedal
so to speak
but we will step on the gospels
just a question of being patient queen
f6
and i think it's time to step on the
step on the gas pedal we can do that in
a couple of different ways now g5 makes
a lot more sense
because it hits the queen
absolutely we should start with g5 and
we can follow up with the move f4
but i'm anticipating
hg in which case we're going to play
bishop takes
and
there will be hell to pay
queen g6 well that's no good because now
notice that these are unforkable spots
so f4 is very likely to win
at the very least a piece but possibly
even the queen
okay so i think a lot of people here
would be tempted to take on c4 and this
is where you know you really have to
demonstrate
um
attention to detail
the first instinct the first question
you always ask yourself should be can i
play f5 anyway and that's what i call
the sam shanklin question because sam is
a big fan of teaching students to do
this right why did we play f4 we played
it to play f5
and rather than automatically getting
scared of a threat we ask ourselves can
we play the move anyway
well what happens if he takes the bishop
and attacks our queen that seems scary
well it's not because once we take his
queen that's actually going to be check
and that's the key detail f5 wins the
game it actually wins the queen
the hilarious thing is the queen is
trapped and if bishop takes f5 we play e
takes f5
and then if queen takes f5
we can certainly take the knight and be
two pieces up but what else can we do
what else do you guys see
in that position
yeah you look at the alignment of the
queen and the king and you see the move
bishop d3 which skewers
uh sorry pins the queen to the king
so the game is over
now the best thing that black can do
here is actually to take on e3
and then after fg to play f takes g6
and and take the rook but that's just a
queen for a rook in a middle game which
is completely winning
this was an easy game i mean our
opponents just played this too passively
but this is what i'm talking about you
know the fortnite scotch really allows
you
in many cases to practice
a basic attacking techniques which is
incredibly valuable
uh
in terms of building a solid foundation
i mean nothing i did here was
remotely uh obscure
perhaps with the exception of queen g2
okay now not bishop takes c4
automatically but bishop d3 winning the
queen but queen g2 is a very findable
move i think you would agree with me if
you know how to think about those
positions queen g2 should occur to you
pretty naturally
okay now what should we take with we can
actually take with a pawn that's the
funny thing and after knight takes e3 we
can play queen e4 check let's do that
knight takes c3 we can play queenie for
check picking off the knight
again notice how i'm just not making
automatic moves i'm questioning
everything
rather than assuming that i can't take
with a certain piece i'm asking myself
what happens if i do
and that's how you really
you know start to notice tactical detail
you notice how much there is
hiding under behind the scenes in a lot
of these positions rookie five well
we're a full queen up
i'm not even gonna comment here let's
play rook hg1 activate the rook
and then try to mate him down the g file
the other rook can come to f1 the knight
can come to e4
whoops all right mouse slipped i guess
he uh shouldn't give up
i'm not slipped rookie one
well fortunately it's not the end of the
world
lol
that's hilarious but now let's not now
slip further or else i'll give up the
queen and lose
that is funny i guess it pays off for
him
all right well we're back to uh
converting the position let's play g
takes h6
okay but but in all seriousness what
should we do here
in all seriousness what should we do now
okay i'm now i'm worried i'm gonna play
queen e6 by accident yeah quincy h track
of course
and then we just start vacuuming up all
the pawns doesn't even matter which ones
we take first just take all of them
take this one
take this one
defending h2 simultaneously
go back to c7 and start taking more of
them
okay
and where should the knight go
let's let's uh let's get this done
at some point you know you just gotta go
for his throat yeah knight d6 now of
course this gives up h2 but after king
c3 it's not hard to establish that uh
the f7 pawn is indefensible if he moves
it then we have knight f7 check winning
the rook so at some point you just got
to stop caring about pawns and just go
for it
you know just just go for the win takes
okay night g5 check makes the most sense
to me just getting the king out
all right
this is
this has been this is dragged on for way
too long
well what should we do now what's the
nicest way to convert this
well queen g3 doesn't actually really do
anything you know the move that i would
play
i'm gonna play a classy move
play queen d8
the point is that
this totally paralyzes him the knight
can't move
and the queen also protects the knight
on g5 and i think in such positions
people forget to use their pawns
i i've seen this so many times when
people convert these big material
advantages they forget to use their past
spots just push the passer
the simplest technique simplest winning
technique in many such positions is just
to make more queens
rather than to use the existing one just
don't forget about that
we can close our eyes and push the queen
defense tonight that's why we put it
there
no but i'm serious that's that's an
important idea
i think i i've seen this with students
you know they'll be up a queen for for
let's say a rook
and
they'll have the possibility of just
taking a bunch of puns and then making
more queens
don't be don't be afraid to do that
now what's the fastest mate going to be
who sees who sees a nice cute little
mate
queen takes g8 and then d8 equals queen
very good
boom
and we can even make a rook if we want
it but i think i might have auto queen
on
yeah definitely definitely make a rook
when you can when it's mate
so bishop e3 now does anybody know what
the main move is for black hair and this
is a classic example of the need to keep
tension
a lot of 14 1500s kind of resort to
releasing the tension by taking
but you know that the bishop on c5 is
hanging no d5 is wrong guys
i mentioned this during the game d5
blunders a piece
you've got to identify undefended pieces
when there's an undefended pieces piece
that's being x-rayed
you have to be particularly
you have to be particularly attentive to
that the move is bishop b6
move is bishop b6 that's the main move
getting the bishop onto a defendant
square
no d6 is bad this was played against me
once
if black plays d6 you can still do this
and then black has
look at this
i had a game like this actually believe
it or not when i was like 1300.
yeah g6 is d6 is not the way okay so
bishop d4 and bishop d4
castles now we preserved the bishop
and uh it had black played rookie 8
which to me is the most testing move
how should white continue here what is
the nicest way of defending e4
and there's a tactical subtlety that
hides behind the correct move
so f3
again creates a
x-ray against an undefended piece
which so you should immediately look at
ways that black can try to get to the c4
pawn and the move d5 is quite nasty here
so if you take it you give up the bishop
with check the move is bishop d3
and you might say well this blocks the
queen's access to d5 so black can go d5
anyway
but if you know a thing or two about
tactics you'll see that this is not not
advisable he takes d5
and what this all ends with
is a discovery on h7
this is a pretty
straightforward concept
okay easy cloud
h6 is a really bad move i don't know
what it is that our opponent is trying
to prevent probably bishop g5
but black can't afford to make more
weaknesses and yet that's exactly what
he did king h7 another unnecessary move
overly cautious maybe here he was
worried about bishop takes h6 but that
is totally not a threat we don't have
any other pieces on the king's side
yeah so we could have gone bishop d3
here that's actually a very very good
move which i didn't even see to be
honest thank you good ass yeah bishop d3
to prepare discover check would be an
excellent alternative but i wanted to
play in accordance with our general plan
[Music]
now last thing i want to say here
is that nigeria iv is not always scary i
think a lot of people are worried about
this move
but many times now black should just
play dc i mean black should play d6
bishop b6 and develop
rather than wasting more time
knight g4 is not always scary in this
case we can just play bishop f4
and and then we can play f3 to chase the
night away winning back the tempo
that we lost moving the bishop back to
f4 does that make sense so
sometimes knight 4 is scary sometimes it
isn't but you should not automatically
try to prevent it okay
so d6f3 this should be six
well redstone asks could blackstar
pushing pawns queen side to counter
attack i mean in general that is the
right approach but look at how much
faster we are black hasn't even begun
and it's not like when black plays b5
it's checkmate
and at this point we're already
basically checkmating black
and and black has not even gotten the
engine started on the queen side so it's
simply too slow and black has nothing
going for him
but yeah the nicest move of the game was
was queen queen g2 i think
it gets the queen
onto a square where protects the pawn
and prepares g5 there was one question
about knight takes f3 and
the important thing to realize and i
think a lot of people really
misunderstand this
in
sharp middle games
two pieces particularly two bishops are
generally much better than the rook
so
look at how many miners are going to be
involved in the attack and this rook on
a8 is not good for anybody white is
completely winning here
so for instance i don't even know what
black should do i mean let's say black
makes a neutral move c6
now we can play rook g1 threatening mate
and in case of rook ga we can get our
bishop out threatening discover check as
we discussed previously
after king h8
there are multiple approaches to a
position like this one of them is to say
well the knight on c3 isn't fulfilling
its potential let's get it into the game
let's go 92 knight g3 knight f5
another approach perhaps a little more
superficial is to play queen h3 and
prepare various sacrifices
bishop d4 is another excellent move
although it doesn't really threaten
anything i mean it's not like we're
threatening to take the knight
but i do like bishop d4 and then maybe
get the knight in via e2 black on the
other hand has again absolutely nothing
going for him and black has no plans
here
um
so remember that two pieces for rook is
not just equal material you shouldn't
think of it that way it's an imbalance
and every imbalance needs to be
evaluated in a case-by-case basis that
means in certain positions the rook can
completely dominate the two pieces
and obviously vice versa and that's
important to understand
in the end game the rook often dominates
the two pieces because the rook can
trampoline from side to side and start
picking off weak pawns
but in the middle game the minor pieces
are excellent attackers and the rook is
not a particularly good defender
okay hopefully that explanation made
sense now we decided on bishop b2 there
are multiple moves here that are
possible
you can play king b1 at some point
bishop b2 prepares f4 that's the whole
point and then the pawns
just rumble up the board with crushing
effect
queen f6 throws more oil on to the fire
by allowing g5 with tempo
and after f4 the game is over
okay maybe hg5 is the last chance but
then bishop g5 and f4 is still winning
still still crashing although black has
black has one attempt in this position
yeah i saw this in the game just have a
cool detail to show you guys what should
black do here black is a a tricky
defensive move
because if you move the knight then the
game is over immediately after f5 yeah
black goes f6 and does anybody see a
really pretty a really pretty response
to this
creative attackers should be able to see
this move
what should white do anytime you have a
bishop on g5 this is a common common
theme in general
no guys bishop f6 blunders the queen
excellent is h4 f5 relinquishes the
defender and allows queen takes g5 with
the queen trade
the move is h4
it's the same fishing line fishing pole
idea right because in the event of fg
you play h takes g5 and black is
busted after knight h6 the funny thing
is you can take on e5
but you can also play bishop h5 trapping
the queen
these sideways bishop moves are very
easy to miss just just
make a note of that in your head
these these sideways bishop moves can be
[Music]
can be easy to miss but you should
always pay attention to your opponent's
queen
and this reminds me of this trick
queen traps in the center are more
common than people realize in the french
there's a line
in the french you could have a line
where b6 this is famous bishop d3 bishop
b7
now you might notice that bishop g5
traps the queen but then if you look a
little bit more carefully you might say
well what's defending the bishop well
it's the knight black can take the
knight and black actually seems to win a
piece
if you take the queen then black takes
our queen and
black emerges a piece of but here there
is a very famous move
does anybody know what it is
queen d2
queen d2 is an amazing move the queen is
still trapped queen takes d4 exploits
and this exploits another tactical idea
but should be five check
so that's actually a cool trap to to be
aware of
yeah so it just shows that the queen can
get trapped in anywhere on the board
yep
yep
okay
[Music]